Speaker 1: And speaking of Jan. six, as I
mentioned, the committee has gotten their hands on
all kinds of new events, new communications, new
text messages, new call logs and. They recently
got information from Ali Alexander himself,
the man who's a founder of Stop the Steal,
helped organize this rally. You know, this
was partially at least his brainchild.
And Ali Alexander has revealed
to the committee that, yeah,
I had communications with several Republican
representatives who some of them now say, like,
Oh, I don't remember ever talking to this guy. But
Alexander absolutely turned this information over
to the committee and said, Here it is. I talked
to these people and the people, of course, were
Representative Paul Gosar, a text exchange with
Representative Mo Brooks and also Andy Biggs
of Arizona. Although he says he did not actually
talk to him on the phone, that was more of an
in-person thing. Pretty interesting, right? So how
do we know Ali Alexander is given the committee
everything he has? Well, because that is actually
what Alexander is charging in a new lawsuit
because the committee still says, We want
your records, we want all your records.
You've given us a lot, right? You know, we asked
for these things. You've given us these things,
but based on what you've given us. This is kind
of indicative that you were talking to people,
and so we need to make sure that you're not
holding anything back. So Alexander has sued the
committee to stop Verizon, his phone carrier,
from turning over the rest of his records.
Unfortunately, purely legally speaking here, I'm
not, you know, determining Alexander's guilt or
innocence in any way. But I will say, having
worked with the best lawyers in this country.
For almost two decades now. The
argument that Alexander is putting
forth to protect his phone records
is about as weak as humanly possible.
Alexander is arguing in his lawsuit that you
cannot have all my phone records because it
contains privileged information. You know my
my my conversations with religious leaders.
My religious advice to other people talks
with my clients, talks with my lawyers,
you can't have that call log information or
those communications because that's privileged.
It's not a stand up, dude. That's a very,
very weak legal argument and one that court
case after court case has shown us doesn't hold up
anyway. This is not to release it to the public.
Right. If it were being released to the public,
sure, you'd probably have an argument there. But
this is for an investigation, for investigatory
purposes and yeah, you can absolutely be compelled
to turn over that information. You know, you
have very little protection at that point,
maybe your communications with your lawyers
could not be turned over. But everything else.
Absolutely not. Like you, you have you're going to
have to turn that over. You can't fight that very,
very weak legal argument here. Let me read this
from Politico. Per Alexander's, the two attorneys,
Jonathan Moseley and Paul Common, are members
of Congress have been on an organizing call
with him in early January. Several were invited,
but he did not make attendance, the lawyer says.
They also said Alexander quote testified he
had phone conversations with Representative
Brooks staff about a dear colleague letter and
how his activists could be helpful. Alexander
said in a since deleted video that he
worked with GOES-R, Biggs and Brooks
to attempt to use Congress's Jan. six session,
certifying Biden's victory as a chance to pressure
lawmakers to overturn the electoral results.
We four schemed up to put maximum pressure on
Congress while they were voting, Alexander said
in the video. Biggs and Brooks have denied meeting
Alexander. GOES-R has appeared at events with
him but has not elaborated on their relationship.
So knowing that OK, and of course,
the quote from that now deleted video.
Do you think Alexander should have to turn over
his entire phone records? Is he being honest that,
look, this is all I have, I don't want to give
you the rest of this because, you know, this is
privileged stuff or is there more that we don't
know about? How much can we trust Ali Alexander?
Now, of course, that's a subjective thing. If it
were me, you know, just personal opinion here,
I don't think I would trust him. I'm not on
the committee. I'm not a lawyer. I don't get
to make that determination. All I can have is my
personal opinion of him, which I just gave you.
So the committee has a decision to make. Do they
just say, all right, Ali, if you're going to sue
us, we don't want to get involved in that.
Whatever, you've been a cooperative person,
thank you very much. We've got what we need
for now will contact you if we need more
or do they fight it and say, Oh no,
we think you've got something to hide.
Who knows where it goes from here. But honestly,
and this is something I was saying since the early
days of this committee, Alexander should
have been the very first person they ever
asked for material from. I know, like I said, he
was the brainchild of Stop the Steal. You know,
why was he not the first if your goal was to find
out what happened that day? Why was the organizer
of the rally not the first person you subpoenaed?
To me, that makes the committee look bad.
That makes it look like they were on some kind of
political hunt to go after other people first. I
mean, why would Steve Bannon subpoenaed before
the guy that organized the rally? That doesn't
make sense to me. And just to play devil's
advocate for a moment, if I were Alexander,
that is something I would bring up in that
lawsuit. So just throwing that out there.
But either way, if he has more information,
he should be compelled to turn it over.
If it's determined that he is being honest, then
OK, he shouldn't have to turn anything else over.
He is one of the few people, let's be honest.
It's actually agreed to go and cooperate with
this committee because he says, You know, I don't
want to get involved in all this other stuff and
challenging it and blah blah blah blah blah. So
look, he knows he has everything to lose from not
cooperating with this committee. So maybe
you do trust him. Maybe you don't. It's not
my determination to make because I'm not sitting
on this committee, but I will say this in closing
here. I think the committee has their work cut out
for them to the point where it's time to appoint
a special prosecutor to really take over this
because I don't think the committee is equipped
to keep doing this on their own. We got a
wonderful bonus show coming up for you. We've got
more talk about COVID. A Republican lawmakers
passed away. We've got Donald Trump and Bill
O'Reilly's rally. And I'm Farron Cousins. Thank
you so much for tuning in today. I will see you
tomorrow and for the rest of the week right here
Unidentified: on The David Pakman Show.